Madame Girault, vraiment,
ça nous fait plaisir de vous
voirdede vous parler. Et donc,
je me demandais où en était
bataille que vous menez,
en ce moment, contre le cancer.
- Oui. Merci, d'abord, d'être
Euh, ça va bien. Ça va bien,
considérant... troisetetits
points. C'est sûr que je suis
en traitement. Je vais...
lendemain, c'est plus difficile,
mais ça va ratativement bien.
Je pense que le fait que jaiaia,
que je sois en congé, ça fait
en sorte que je peux vraiment
me reposer davantage. Puis je ml
point j'étais fatiguée aussi,
à quel point j'ai étiré
l'élastique.EtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtE,
dans votre situation, c'est ee
vous étiez une femme très
sportive, très active.
Vous avez jamais fumé.
- Non.
- Et là, vous vous battez
contre un cancer
- Oui. Le cancer du poumon,
de ce que j' a appris, en fait,
il y a deux cancers du poumon.
Il y a le cancer du poumon des
qui attaque les non-fumeurs,
s s gens qui n'ont jamais fumé
de leur vie. Parce que moi,
je n'ai jamais fumé de ma vie,js
rien pris d'autre. J'étais
excessivement sportive, j'étais
quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup,
beaucoup de sport. D'arerererers
les postes que j'ai eus dans
ma carrière, c'était le sport.
- Ah oui.
- Donc làJe fais le deuil de mae
politique et je fais le deuil
de ma carrière... de mon
environnement sportif, parce que
- Donc, imimagine que vous
pouvez pas vous intéresser trop,
trop à la campagne électorale
- C'est sûr que je vais m'y
tétéresser quand même. Parce que
bon, mon coeur est là, hein.
Mon coeur est avec touscocococos
députés, mes collègues
ministres. Donc, c'est sûr
que je vais y porter attention.
beaucoup ce que vous avez fait.
Est- q que vous avez
l'impression quand même que vous
quittez, vous avez accomplimpmp?
- Oui. Je pense que j'ai fait
un bon tour de table. Je suis
satisfaite de ce que j'ai fait,
autant à l'internationststststss
internationales, qu'ici dans
le comté. Mais je pense qu'on
avait eu des très bonnes bases,
là, pour plu
- Vous
économique? Qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire, au fond?
Parce que... qu'est-ce que ça
change pour les délégations
- Ça change beaucoup, parce que
les délégations du Québec,
avant que j'arrive, avant
notre arrivée, en fait, en 2018,
s'orientaient davantage sur
de la diplomatie dnfnfluence
et de la diplomatie sociale.
Donc...
- Il y avait une petite partie
qui étai c c'était plus des
interactions avec les consuls,
avec les ministres, avec...tétéé
économique, donc diplomatied'af.
Il y a plusieurs personnes
dans les délégations qui onta as
qui avaient des profils beaucoup
plus économiques, pour être
capable aussi d'avoir
ce langage-là a
d'affaires, parce que le
l'objectif éitit de développer
les affaires avec les différents
pays ou
Et c'est ce que les pays veulent
auss I Il y a beaucoup de pays
qui nous disaient : "Écoutez, on
on fait affaire avec les
Chinois, on fait affaire...
mais on voit pas les Québécois,
des Québécois." Et c'est ce
qu'on a développé avec le virage
économique. Donc, ça a été
un gros changementgagagagagagag.
- Et donc ça, ça donne quoi?
Des contrats? Plus de contrats?
- Oui! Quand on voit des beaux
cont
SNC, comme Hydro-Québec qui
vient de signer un énorme
contrat, comme les autobus
Lions, tous ces contrats-là
par les délégations.
Ils sont signés au niveau
du ministère de l'Économie,
mais ils sont travaillés
ce genre de contrat, ce sont des
mois, et des fois des années.
tout un parcours, hein, quand
on regarde ça. Vos parents
ont quitté Haïti, vous êtes née
- Oui.
- Vous avez grandi en Gaspésie.
- À Gaspé!
- Pour vous retrouver,
éventuellement, miststre
dans un gouvernement Legault.
C'est exceptionnel! Ça a été, ,e
votre place?
- Oui et non, je dirais. Je suis
quelqu'un qui fonce beaucoup,
donc qui aime les déjojojojojojs
différents. Puis en même temps,
quand on cherche les défis,
il faut s'attendre aussi à avoir
enjeux, puis être capable
de passer par-dessus. Et j'ai
toujours été quelqu'un de trèsee
pour ça que ça m'a amenée aussi
à ce parcours-là. Parce que
j'ai fait différents posteset ce
de ministre-là que j'avais,
ce poste de députée et de
ministre, j'avais l'impressionts
de tarte de ma carrière, qui
étaient des points de tarte
différentes, qu'on avait misess,
là, j'avais la tarte au colelet.
J'étais vraiment sur mon X.
- Pour une enfant d'orig
haïtienne, dans une petite ville
comme Gaspé, où vous avez
grandi, là, vous avez été bien
accueillie?
on était presque les chouchous
à Gaspé. On était très pedede
familles haïtiennes. Je pense
qu'on était deux familles
la curiosité. Puis, honnêtement,
j'ai des très, tèès bons
souvenirs. Je n'ai aucun
souvenir négatif de Gaspé.
ma classe de maternelle.
Je msosouviens, la première fois
qu'on est rentrés à l'école,
on m'a présentée ma petite amiet
Lyne. Et aujourd'hui,
elle est encore mon amie.
(rire)
Maintenant, elle ee e e e e e en
entend, en ce moment...
- Oui.
- Les difficultés qu'on peut
avoir, i
notamment, et tout. Vous êtes
consciente, quand même,
de ces difficultés.
- Tout à fait, j'en suis tout
vécu. Faut pas se leurrer, là,
faut pas se cacher la tête
dans le sable non plus, là.
J'ai vécu des commentaires,
je me suis présentée, ici, dans
le comté de Bertra, , il y avait
des commentaires, là. Mais bon,
on passe par-dessus, puis
plus tard on m'a élue,
j'ai eu e e grosse majorité,
puis ça va super bien.
- Qu'est-ce que vous avez comme
qui rentrent, qui font leurpreme
- Sautez. Ça vaut la peine.
Je sais que ça fait peur.
Puis, moi, j'ai pris beaucoup
de temps à prendre ma décision.
J'ai été une de celles qu'on aû.
à qui on a dû parler à de
nombreuses reprises avant
que je dise oui. Parce que, bon,
mais de loin. Mais je vous le
dis, allez-y, ça vaut vraiment
la peine. Puis, c'est vraimentor
les choses.
- Vous, ça vous a apporté
beaucoup, la politique?- - - -Çé
avec les gens. Vous ayez v
les gens tout à l'heure, là :
"Oh, Bonjour! Comment
Donc, les gens, les gens
nous reconnaissentleles gens
apprécient. Et ils apprécient
le fait qu'on x.x.x.x.x.x.x.x.x.
- Et donc là, avec
cette campagne qui s'amorce,
ça va vous manquer?
- É
c'était... Moi, j'avais même pas
de question dans ma tête. Je me
représentais, c'était certain.
Certain, certain. C'était...
c'était une évidence, là.
C'était même pas
une évidence. D'ailleurs,
j'ai pris beaucoup de temps à me
décider à ne pas me présenter,
pa
ça allait un peu bien,
je me disais : ah, mais oui,
j'ai la force, je peux le faire.
Le lendemain, jeçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçg
à prendre la décision, mais
j'ai pas tellement le choix.
Si je veux vraiment m'occuperere
me sortir de cette de tout ça,
faut vraiment que je prenne soin
de moi.
- Vous, pour vous, la suite,
vous voyez ça comment?
- Moi, la suite? Euh...
Surtout faire en sorte que
traitements-là, que j'aie assez
de force pour passer à travers.
J'ai perdu beaucoup d'énergie,
dodonc je veux en récupérer.
Idéalement, j'aimerais bien
recommencer à faire un peu dea,.
c'est une grande peine pour moi,
là. Donc, j'aimerais beaucoup,cr
à faire un peu de sport.
L'année passée, j'ai pas pu
faire de ski, fait que j'ai
ma passe de ski cette année.
irires)
Alors cette année, je prie que
je puisse faire un peu de ski!Js
une journée à la fois, c'est
vraiment ça. Puis, comme
je ne suis pas quelqu'un de
très, très patiisisisisisisisisp
ma patiente.
- On vous souhaite le meilleur,
- Merci.
- Du courage aussi.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Je sais que rcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcr.
- Ah, merci, Madame Galipeau.
Ça me fait vraiment plaisir